m
[Musique]
bonjour mon invité peu sur le pôle t d
aix pour parler en fait la conquête de
nos territoires
donc je vous parlais de la conquête des
territoires que j'ai fait en traversant
la france est aussi mon territoire
intérieur
donc je m'appelle pierre je te faire
j'ai 42 ans
je suis ferronnier d'art et aux
compagnons du tour de france des deux
bords demi j'ai été reçu au rang des
compagnons le 28 mars 2010 sous le nom
symbolique deux avignonnais la quête de
l'outil j'ai laissé happer le bep le bp
de niveau du bts et le diplôme de
compagnons du devoir ferronnier du tour
de france et accessoirement je suis
aussi membre du célèbre collectif de dj
avignonnais arlington trotteurs d'âge de
mes cinq ans je me rappelle le souvenir
du celui du feu le bruit du marteau sur
l'enclume des gerbes et des gerbes
d'étincelles dans l'atelier jusqu'à mes
16 ans je passais le plus de mon temps à
traîner dans ce dans la forge de mon
village où mes parents et moyennes
habitants à 50 mètres de cette forge
pour moi c'était un rêve de pratiquer ce
métier là et de le faire comme je
voulais pas mais seulement mais mes
parents ne voyez pas comme cela ils
pensaient que c'était une lubie et que
c'était un métier dur qui gérerait pas
et que je passerai pétrole choses plus
tard mais j'arrive quand même à les
convaincre
dire que c'était vraiment là bas j'avais
choisi pour mon futur
mon plan a comme on pourrait dire en ce
moment et attiré comme un aimant en fait
je voulais travailler les mettrons donc
j'ai pris le minitel et l'époque pour
ceux qui l'ont connu j'ai trouvé une
adresse et un numéro de téléphone sur
marseille et je suis parti après une
semaine de pré stages et des évaluations
avec des cours du soir
et puis d une immersion en entreprise
nous voilà accepté comme apprenti on
m'envoie ya donc amusant un petit
village à 10 km de reims
mais dans ma tête ça ce n'est plus c'est
dans la mouise amusant avec des super
beaux paysages du nord-est de la france
autrement dit des champs de betteraves à
perte de vue mais bon je pense qu on s'y
fait à force
là bas j'ai rencontré de chouette gars
j'ai vu du banc le champagne à l'apéro
et pas que et à cette époque là je ne
savais vraiment pas à ce que c'était que
le tour de france
et puis à force voilà on tombe dedans
du coup il faut savoir que le
compagnonnage est issu des anciens de
voir non pas les devoirs qu'on a à
l'école
c'est le devoir en fait c'est sa
définition et être engagée à quelque
chose par la morale par la loi par sa
condition par la bienséance et par
l'honneur
ça calme il faut savoir qu'au 19e siècle
les compagnons l'issue des différents
devoir se faisait la guerre car ils ne
se reconnaissaient pas entre eux alors
que leur fonctionnement était le même à
savoir aller de ville en ville et de
chantier en chantier tout en pratiquant
des cours du soir sur l'art du trait la
technologie du métier mais pourtant leur
fonctionnement était le même mais il ne
se reconnaissait pas entre eux à l'heure
actuelle on peut dire que le
fonctionnement est toujours pareil on
appelle les compagnons qui travail
serein dans un atelier on les appelle
des pays et les compagnons qui travaille
sur un chantier
un échafaudage on les appelle les
coteries alors plus vulgairement pays au
sol coterie en l'air le company ej et le
compagnonnage actuelle en fait est
constitué de trois mouvements qui sont
l'association ouvrière la fédération
compagnonnique des métiers du bâtiment
et l'union compagnonnique des devoirs
unis dont je fais partie elle réussit l
issue de ce compagnon jean fait actuel
aussi est issu du legend donc danser les
gens dont on retrouve en fait des
personnages emblématiques comme le
maître jacques le père sobiz et le roi
salomon aux huiles le roi salomon le
maître d'ouvragé une femme tente de
jérusalem mais tout ceci ce sont des
légendes l'histoire réelle on la connaît
vraiment pas on sait que ça peut venir
du moyen âge
les bâtisseurs de cathédrales mais tout
ça aussi c'est peut-être pour se
raccrocher à quelque chose en fait et se
donner du coeur à l'ouvragé lui un
message très important dans l'école
perdiguier compagnons menuisiers
menuisiers serruriers du devoir de
liberté dit avignonnais la vertu
écrivain et citoyens du peuple de 1805 à
8,75 bon je sais pas si ça m'intéresse
trop ce genre de choses mais en tous les
cas les compagnons de cette époque
traire conscience de s'unir et donc du
coup aller de l'avant et être plus dans
la fraternité que dans les guerres
fratricides ces voix il faut savoir
aussi qu'à l'heure actuelle en fait dans
le compagnonnage et compagnons doivent
être propres et bien billets par rapport
au règlement intérieur en fait dans les
maisons de compagnons
pourquoi parce qu'on doit sortir son
quotidien de la vie de travail et postée
le porter le costard cravate comme là
maintenant je suis en habit de
compagnons comme quotidiennement en
réunion ou dans un banquet une compagne
ne savent pas que là en fait on est
confronté en changeant de ville chaque
année au voyage à rencontre des gens que
l'on rencontre au travail que l'on
effectué dans différents ateliers aux
paysages à la culture à l'architecturé
chaque année c'est le renouveau c'est le
reset
on repart à zéro on a l'impression de
pury à savoir quand on rentre dans les
sociétés compagnonnique comme je vous ai
cités il ya plusieurs bons il ya trois
mouvements principaux pays d
dizaines de devoir compagnonnique ça
serait très loin vous l'expliqué le
nombre de voix tient bon les plus connus
ses compagnons du devoir moi je
j'appartiens aux compagnons des devoirs
unis mais ça serait loin à vous
expliquer tous les devoirs et puis ça
vous intéresserait pas du coup on rentre
comme apprenti jeunes ou stagiaire puis
après quand on rendrait pendant la
société compagnonnique on est admis
aspirants jeune homme ou ou affiliés
selon les sociétés
du coup on porte une couleur on donne
une couleur qui est celle que j'ai reçu
quand j'étais admis aspirants donc cette
couleur verte en fait et représente
beaucoup de choses mais pour atteindre
et pour avoir cette couleur là on doit
aller au delà nous de nous mêmes et
comme on arrive à ce stade là on va dire
par pas par la force des choses c'est
parce que les compagnons nous mettre en
taille en taille en taille ça veut dire
que l'on apprend pas forcément grand
chose mais que l'on nous donne en fait
on se donne à nous mêmes un objectif
d'aller au delà de nous mêmes donc on
fait vulgairement une maquette une pièce
dans le monde profane en appel c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre
c'est plus en voir et tour déjà je ne
sais pas et pendant un an un peu moins
on travaille là dessus
en plus des cours du soir des cours du
samedi
en plus notre travail quotidien en
entreprise et on se présente à la
critique devant les compagnons le jour j
100 termine à temps parce qu'il faut
quand même termine attend aussi parce
qu'il ya des fêtes de cayenne et des
fêtes de saint patron et donc on a
terminé à temps pour cette fête là avec
cette pièce qu'on présente donc une
maquette avec un dessin une épure et un
dossier si la critique favorable
on passa à l'initiation rue eric donc la
couleur je vous ai présenté
on vous l'a on nous la donne de façon
britt janyk voilà on subit une
initiation et ulic compagnonnique et
puis plus tard donc quelques années
après on sent un autre défi encore mais
bien plus important qui est su de la
réception pour être reçus au rang des
compagnons donc c'est pareil ça dure un
an et là bon mais on y va un peu plus et
on est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
assidus dans ce qu'on fait et on se
lance méga défi quoi essayer de se
dépasser encore plus que vous considérez
passé avant et là on reçoit cette
couleur là
donc pour ma société c'est cette
couleur-là cette couleur rouge pour
d'autres sociétés compagnonnique ça peut
être plein de couleurs mais il ya
beaucoup de couleurs qui sont
représentés donc une fois ce travail est
terminé on passe aussi notre stade
d'initiation rituel iq et du coup on
reçoit un nom de compagnons qui porte
une vertu ou pas moi tout à l'heure en
arrivant je voulais dire c'est
avignonnais la quête de l'outil après je
suis arrivé qu'un chapeau et une canne
donc tous les compagnons ne porte pas de
chapeau et les cannes comme ça c'est une
canne particulière c'est la can du
rouleur les chapeaux du rouleur
le rouleur chez les compagnons c'est le
maître de cérémonie c'est sulky qui vont
les travaux compagnonnique qui les
fermes parce que tout est codifié au
niveau d'un rituel bien particulier
c'est très militaire mais c'est comme ça
le conte panache c'est comme ça on fait
le tour de france on bâille est en
voyage de ville en ville on apprend son
métier avec d'autres avec
des gens qui sont là de passage pas de
passage mais de toute façon au départ on
rentre dans une société comme ça pour
apprendre un métier
et puis en fait on découvre une famille
une fraternité et cette fraternité en
fait c'est le fait de se retrouver face
à soi même par rapport au travail est un
exercice pour une pièce ou un
chef-d'oeuvre
pour ma part j'ai fait un trident pour
être aspirants et après un rubik's cube
pour être reçu compagnon
ça m'a demandé beaucoup d'efforts
beaucoup de temps j'ai assez souffert
mais j'y suis arrivé et quand on arrive
au bout de tout ça en fait on se rend
compte que que la vie est une sorte de
dédale un labyrinthe en fait est que
pour ceux pour apprendre à se connaître
il faut d'abord connaître savoir
connaître les autres et pour ma part je
pense que de la pierre brute à la pierre
taillée du minerai de brut à la barre de
fer ce que l'on donne à la matière la
matière nous laurent comme un miroir de
ce que l'on dit dans pouvant espérer un
jour pour à transmuter l'ouvrier en
oeuvriers
[Applaudissements]